in three 2
[Music]
ex so good good good
good name anyone but him I didn't
approve him you know that you are
literally the last person on Earth I
want to see slap the out of you I
really could and I'm open to that in a
safer
environment you been a ghost no phone
call no
text it's not like I didn't want to
apologize you don't have to explain
anything it was just a
flame so how have you
been God I hate that thumbs up stun guy
stuff I'm the director we're going to
set this man on fire you're a stunk guy
we need to to keep it profesh profes is
my middle name you said your middle name
was
danger how do we do
boss really yeah holster that it's
holstered it's done forget you you never
saw
it Tom
Ryder the biggest action star on the
planet is missing you need to bring him
back on Jody's movie is dead why me
you're a stump man nobody's going to
notice you that's your job no offense I
mean some taking you find Ryder save
Jody's film you get the love of your
life back I'm not the hero I'm just the
double not today you're
not Tom we already need you back on set
[Music]
pal
you
dead body on Ice he was so dead Gail he
was super
dead he has got himself involved with
some shady
people I have no choice I had to do
something Jason boor
they were trying to kill
me and not in a fun way you can make it
you can make it you can't make it it's
too dangerous got me
stairs what happened to your face you
look terrible you look
amazing you fall down you get right back
up how far would you go for the one that
you
love I'll BL you drink when this is over
engage your
core Yeah Boy
St you doing later want to go to a beach
somewhere drink a spicy Margarita make
some bad decisions
yes the heart and you're to
[Applause]
blame